I hope they got a glimpse of the Titanic
before it ended
wouldn't that be nice
and then a Megalodon shark just got him
but
which I don't think exists anymore but
I hope they got a glimpse of it
I hope they got a little glimpse of it
right as they
because this is a movie by the way
don't think for a minute
this is not a movie two pakistanis in
there
diversity honey
no not Jesus Christ thank you Lord
because now the new movie rules get up
the new movie rules what you need to be
eligible for an Academy Award I think
you need 30 marginalized and you got
them in that tin can the new rules to be
considered for an Academy Award you need
to have like a certain amount of
cripples
I believe uh I that's not the term
anymore
um you know people that
you don't have issues what do you call
them what do you call the [__] now
disabled disabled person I should have
known that but it just you've got to
have like 30
disabled or other or something like you
got to have some different people in
there and they don't mean Eastern
European either they want you know the
different shades which I'm down with but
it's these rules are stupid because then
how do you tell period pieces and you
make like a black Trans person the king
of England it's like well that's not
exactly history is it
um you know I mean you're making Laverne
Cox
play the Queen of England I mean is that
is that the answer does that help racism
it seems more racist in a weird way
um at least 30 percent of all actors in
secondary and more minor roles are from
at least two of the following
underrepresented groups women
racial or ethnic group
lgbtq plus people with cognitive or
physical disabilities who are deaf or
hard of hearing now that's how they're
gonna get away with it they're gonna say
this whole white background cast they're
[__]
they're dumb
they'll go up to them and go no watch
and they won't move
they go there uh
this whole background cast is severely
autistic they are all white but they are
severely altered we're talking Rain Man
reciting math it's bad I mean there is
no eye contact on this production so
please let us win an Academy Award
because we we you know we're doing a
movie about [__] I don't know
whatever they're doing right pilgrims
and we can't make them uh Lebanese maybe
we can Lebanese look white it's a bad
example we can't make them uh uh
anything other than like white appearing
because we're making a movie about the
colonists
the colonists the colonizing that
everyone's talking about that was done
by Whitey so they got to be white but
they're severely autistic everyone in
this town scene that you're watching God
severe severe
inspection main storyline subject matter
again to be a for an Academy Award the
main story lines themes or Narrative of
the film is centered on an
underrepresented group I don't even know
what this means women racial ethnic
lgbtq people with cognitive this is
going to destroy
there's an actor watching this who's
like making a face right now because he
knows it's over
he knows it's over
it's all over
no it's uh it's done it's done this
kills it anybody who's making anything
artistic with this crap
it's over it's not going to be able to
get done this paint by numbers stuff is
going to drain this business of the last
few creative people that it has in it
it's going to replace them with order
takers and box Checkers and you're gonna
get a lot of garbage
succession is a great show because it's
about one family understood
you can't make succession a show that's
about everybody that's ever lived
and they all have some type of equal
representation it's about the murdochs
who they call the Roy's a rich white
family
whose patriarch was from another country
Australia I think it's succession it's
Scotland or whatever but so stories
cannot be told this way if they are told
this way it's going to be ruined now
however this can works
you got the Pakistani guy and his and by
the way
if they're found alive
they because of how good the movie could
be they should be quietly killed
like quietly once they get to the top
all of them should be quietly
send the seals in shoot them
because the movie needs to end the movie
because this could be a good one and you
have the diversity and you have
you know and then you say one of them's
an autist too like one of the other
white guys is you know he just keeps
reciting the same quote or whatever but
the the point is once they get to the
end of the movie like they're staring
they finally see the Titanic you know
and they see it
and they see the Titanic
um
and
they're just looking at it and it's
beautiful it's everything they'd imagine
it's just this this you know mesmerizing
beautiful sight that's what was worth
all of their lives
you know and they and they and they say
and it's just such a great movie because
it's so controlled it's in that thing
and it's the lead up to it and then The
Descent and then the problems and then
wondering if it's gonna be okay
and I mean just to me I would see it you
know and I don't I don't
I don't
I don't really get too excited about
things but as a [__] film because we
all want to kind of here's the thing
we all want to be in the can but not
like we're all curious about what's
going on in the can
but we can't we don't want to be in it
many of us don't have the money to be in
it but we also don't want to die in
however they met their end we don't want
it but the great movies are the ones
that put you in the places you don't
want to be
without any threat of danger
so we want to be in that can and we want
to see how it went down and then you
know
I would be very excited to see what they
could do with this
and it's diverse
and it's about it's about people and
it's a great movie because it's about
people wanting more they want to feel
they want the experience they want to
see the Titanic it's a once in a
lifetime I think it's the father and a
son it's a it's a you know the guy could
be like you know it's the great Explorer
who's like I wonder if my children even
miss me and the kid's like you know like
uh you know uh [__] you know singing
uh you know what's My Age Again at the
Blink 182 concert like it's all there
you have it all
the guy's like I should have spent more
time with my stepson
who was convicted last year of
harassment
instead of thinking about exploring the
ruins of the Titanic I should have been
with my stepson you know and then they
just cut to the stepson and he's like I
bet this is growing up
it's like
all of the elements of the human tragedy
are here people don't care about you the
great things you do often distance you
from the people that are near you and at
the end of the day this guy is sitting
in this can going down to the Titanic to
just try to get he just wants something
out of light that he's not getting and
his [__] stepson
is is a in a Blink 182 concert trying to
get whatever thing out of life that's
his version of the [__] whatever you
know it's his version of the Titanic
just standing in a Blink-182 concert
hoping it's one of these Emo's girls
pops out of tent and you know he doesn't
start vomiting or do something stupid
and he's just trying to live his life
and this guy's trying to live his life
in a can with this Pakistani businessman
and his son and it it's it's it's every
it's the whole spectrum of The Human
Experience and one
great sad story that's captivated
everyone because it's got something for
everyone that's where everyone's talking
about it because it's got something for
everyone it has dreams it has nightmares
it has family Dynamics it has wealth it
has money it has class it has Adventure
these are the things that people like
it's a great it's a great story it's so
good
that if there is any chance
that they're found alive they must be
killed
to save distribute it only works if they
die
if they are bailed out at the last
minute it is no longer a good story it's
actually annoying
it's a nut to see them get away with it
they can't get away with it
they must die not for me I don't care
for the story for the film
for the cathartic moment we're having
right now this lets a little pressure
there's a lot of people
you know working [__] jobs who need to
see a billionaire go down in a submarine
every now and again
they need it if you're working at
Popeye's in the hood
and you're dealing with all kinds of
crazy stuff you know
every now and then you need to see a
white billionaire eat it in a [__]
submarine you need to hear about that
[__]
it's good it keeps the gears grinding of
society not for me I don't care does it
bother me I hope they're all alive
but they're not
they're not they're not they died
they exploded trying to see the Titanic
they exploded the pressure exploded them
they were just like
and they went all over the ocean and
then the Sharks go
and the Sharks don't care
they don't care do they
they don't care at all
they don't care that they're eating
30 percent racial or ethnic group
representation
do the Sharks care about that they don't
care about that at all
they're just eating so I I do believe
and I love and I love and appreciate
everyone
on all sides of this because I like when
people get into things
I I I do like this is like an online
digital block party
that we all got into for a moment and
there's something beautiful it's got
something for everyone and everybody was
kind of in it you didn't have to know
and people were doing great content
that black chick who did some great [__]
about this you find The Tick Tock where
she's like wait a minute and you had to
be strapped in and you had to be
[__] like she did I don't know
what you want but I was laughing so hard
this was great content
Applause to her and everyone who's using
this right now to make content all the
creators
all the creators out there that are
using the debts of these people these
people that got exploded in a can that
we'll never know and don't care about
and stop pretending we care
from our friends in Russia
but everyone out there who's using their
creativity
to really nail them
it's I I I'm proud to be part of this
community I'm dead serious because it is
we can we can still have fun
we're still this we you don't have to
give up on the Internet we don't have to
give up on this stuff we can still it
can still be fun we can still utilize
all of this technology to do great stuff
and and sink our teeth into these
stories and and and have a and learn and
learn about life
and that's what we did with this story
and I think I don't care I'm oh this
will go out Saturday I don't it's done
for me I don't care what they find it's
done it's I've had my moment with it
I've had a beautiful moment with it
it doesn't matter if they're found alive
and they will not they'll never be found
they'll never be found
because
they're gone forever now Into the Depths
into the darkness of the Sea Under the
Sea
um
and and and that's the end for them and
and it's the end for me even if there
are new developments I I believe we draw
the line there
um
take the risks you want to take
every now and then I'd take a risk I get
in an airplane to do my job
and that airplane that's a risk but I do
it
I get in a vehicle
and I drive that's a risk
you know what I mean
for many many years I uh
filled myself with drugs alcohol bad
food horrible people I was around you
know some of the scum of the Earth
I associated with real monsters
um I had high levels of stress
I neglected myself and others I
neglected relationships with friends and
family I ruined my credit score I was a
bad borrowing risk I had my license
suspended multiple times I did not pay
bills I had liens and judgments leveled
against me I I've done risky things you
know
I've we all have our own can
and we're all trying to see the Titanic
is what I mean and you never know when
it's going to be you never know when
your can
will get called
and we all have to decide who we're
going to get into the can with and go
see the Titanic this is a fact
this is all true and and you're not
better than these people you're not
better than them and you will not Escape
the Fate you will still you'll meet that
fate
somewhere
one day
you'll be handing someone uh
a McChicken
through the drive-through and they're
gonna shoot you in the head
and
but that's gonna happen to a lot of
people
no
no no
but you see
it's not
it's you know
enjoy the time enjoy the can
enjoy the can
you don't know how long he got in the
Canton Troy the can isn't it gonna be
great when we see the Titanic I wonder
what will feel like
uh when we see the Titanic how much will
our lives change what's it going to be
like when I'm out on a date with a girl
and she's got a big sloppy tits out and
I tell her that I went to the Titanic
she's gonna rip open her [__] and say
get in here and she's gonna swallow my
whole body with it when I tell her the
tale of seeing the Titanic with my old
man and a couple of [__] British
explorers 11
000 or 12 000 feet uh forty Thousand
Leagues Under the Sea whatever
and she is gonna be wet like the ocean
when I tell her that and all my friends
are gonna Envy me the world is gonna
Envy me
because I will know something and I will
have seen something the day I've never
seen
enjoy the can
it all goes
to the same place